يبدو ان متى قاعده تحاول استثمار الازمات
التي يعيشها تويتر لتكون منافسه له في اهم
ميزاتها القائمه في النصوص القصيره متى
مشاهدينا عبر تطبيقها انستقرام تسعى لي ان
يكون شهر يونيو المقبل هو شهر اشهر
التطبيق الجديد مباراه تكنولوجيا يعتقدون
ان تطبيق مثل جديد سيكون منافسا قويا
لتويتر خصوصا وان يقوم على فكره الاعتماد
على الموستائين من تويتر في عصر ايلون
ماسك الشركه الام لفيسبوك قد تعمق ازمه
تويتر لاسيما وانا تطبيق المنتظر قد يسحب
بساط
من تويتر الى انستجرام
احنا دائما ما الحب الا للحبيب الاولي فلي
تعودنا عليه بالبدايه رح نضلنا معه
هذه نقطه جدا ممتازه تطبيق تعودنا عليه
اكثر من عشر سنوات وبالتالي هذا
التطبيق طبيعته ما بين النصوص والصور
والفيديوهات الطبيعه اللي وصلت له هذه
الطبيعه هي اللي نحتاجها على المنصه
الانستجرام تعودنا عليها كتطبيق فعلي
للصور والفيديوهات قاعدين يحاولوا اخر
ثلاث سنوات يحولوه الى تطبيق اكثر
للفيديوهات نوعا ما قادرين ينجحوا في
زاويه ولكن لو سالتكم الحين كم منكم
يستخدم انستقرام ماسنجر واللي موجود صار
له اكثر من سنه حق المراسلات حق الماسنجر
اصلا شكرا عرفني
فهنا نقدر نقول انه صعب جدا تيجي تاخذ
جزئيه ضخمه من المستخدمين لتطبيق اخر ولكن
ممكن تستحوذ على الجزء من اصلا اللي
موجودين